obviously this has been an incredible
week for the gays and and you know it's
only going I was about to say it gets
better it only will continue to get
better that's that's become very clear
to me so what do you guys see as the
future for the gay movement I mean
obviously there's some legal stuff that
needs to be done but you guys are all
fear that once we get equality once
we're truly equal and all that stuff
that we will lose something as a
community something sort of special that
we have now I mean there's definitely
something to be said for feeling like
Alec was saying that you're part of like
a radical section and we gotta hold on
to our culture and keep it going and
keep our traditions going and then we
just become like everybody else here
afraid we're gonna be boring but gays
are the superior race so superior and
create the most beautiful things in the
world yes I said it
gay power somehow we will figure out a
way to multiply there you go what do you
think about love no I mean I think that
the best thing that we can happen for
people and it's not gay people are
straight people is that people accept
each other for who they are and don't
place judgment or fear on each other I'm
hoping that we don't keep calling it gay
marriage how about we just call it more
marriage yes or marriage um so yeah I'm
very pleased with you know gay people
becoming normal or boring it's gonna be
like a no big deal type of thing I mean
two kids coming out now me kids are
giving you calling all the basic [ __ ]
Wow okay yeah that's just becoming that
thing like oh you know that's how she
being yeah that's how she be yeah really
what do you think the future the gays
you know I like that I can be part of an
age an era when I have kids I can
actually say to them you know when I was
your age or your welcome cuz I made this
a lot easier for you you know
actually have something behind it you
know yeah I like how you think your
child is going to be gay alright well
you know I mean even if they're not I'm
gonna find a reason to use that but you
know in reality I I think even though
we've obviously came a huge way in the
past 48 hours
um I think we still have a tremendous
amount to go and we're free we have all
these states that still need to be
passed before it becomes federal
hopefully and then we still have issues
surrounding kids adoption you know some
families still have a hard time at gay
parents adopting kids out so I mean
there's definitely still milestones to
hit before we're in the clear so we
still have that you know secret society
of gay demand that we can maintain for a
little while yeah now Alec you are
married and have a kid so I just sort of
like the gay from the future right I
have a gay from the future vodkas free
in the future now here's what happened
my son came to live with us when he has
5 years old but he was from her he was
from Compton right and and we kind of
set up from the beginning we're really
clear about the kind of family we were
like some people have two moms some
people have a mom and a dad you have two
dads and look at us we're all different
I'm Asian
Papa's Cajun which means he's from
Louisiana so he's kind of French and
you're african-american that we all fit
together because we're a forever family
so my son's dropped off at kindergarten
for the very first time and he's running
back to the car you know cuz we're
picking him up at the end of the day and
two little girls go seize the two dads
in the Volvo in the gay dad's station
wagon right there they go you have two
dads and my sons I'm good yes why
because because we're French
and the two other girls kind of wet and
then went off so that's the future it's
gonna be like okay it's just no big deal
free future of games buys all the
letters just wish that we can stop using
gay as an adjective to describe people I
feel like it's just let's just be people
and not have to put that word in front
of it yeah wouldn't the point is at the
end of the day for us to not have to do
panels like this eventually yes this
will be exactly alright cool well I
really thank you guys for coming out and
doing then heart Johnny McGovern I'm
Dave Rubin I want to thank the Young
Turks obviously who produced the show
and let me say what I want which is all
any comedian or gay person really ever
wants I also want to thank YouTube for
throwing this we are gonna have some
drinks right now and a final thought the
video that I showed you guys earlier of
my grandmother she actually passed away
this morning and it's it's really it's
okay she lived a wonderful life and
taught me for everything that you saw in
that video
she taught me and to be better and to be
kind and and now it's time to drink so
let's let's have some fun